oyster and it is time to celebrate
National Oysters Rockefeller day with
Hearthstone kitchen and seller at Red
Rock Casino Resort and Spa and here to
give us a lesson in the delicacy is Chef
Dawn and click Hospitality senior
director in restaurant marketing Aida
Gilman welcome YouTube thank you for
having me I'm very excited about this
because I feel like I'm going to learn
something I we all know about oysters or
maybe we don't know a lot about them but
what about Oysters Rockefeller what is
Oysters Rockefeller oysters Rockefeller
is a classic New Orleans dish that takes
some fresh oysters from the sea and at
Hearthstone we're putting a lobster
spinach cream sauce inside of them and
we bake them in our Peach wood burning
oven and then we sprinkle them with a
little bit of Parmesan and bread crumbs
oh man and your your presentation is the
best we're going to say that for the end
here but how how do we even shuck an
oyster I keep hearing that how do you do
it you gotta have a good clean sharp
oyster knife and then you get into the
tip right here and squeeze it go back
let it pop oh do it back is there a
pearl in there uh I hope I hope so I
hope so clean the oyster and then you
want to get it clean from the abductor
flip it over so a nice presentation side
and then we have a nice clean oyster
ready to go that is beautiful and I eat
a great special on oysters here today
what's going on correct so today for
National Oyster Rockefeller day we have
uh six Oyster Rockefeller for 32 dollars
available today but tomorrow for all the
oyster lovers out there Wednesdays is at
Hearthstone it's a fresh oysters for a
dollar and change wow every Wednesday
fresh chocolate oysters and uh yeah so
we have this available Hearthstone is
fantastic inside Red Rock if you've
never been uh Chef you got to show us
about these these oysters in the
presentation here because really I think
your presentation is truly a star at
Hearthstone absolutely so these oysters
come to your table side
um flaming on fire we'll put a little
bit more brandies a little bit more show
and yes we do go through a lot of
oysters on Wednesdays we start with 2
000 oysters every single Wednesday and I
promise you we're gonna sell out so
please come down and enjoy the fresh
oysters it really is the freshest food
the tastiest food and I've never had
Oysters Rockefeller before I'm excited
to give this one a try I've always kind
of shied away from oysters but this
actually you put put cheese on there
all right so check out Hearthstone they
are having a special you don't want to
miss to celebrate Oysters Rockefeller
day and uh thank you guys for joining us
on the show thank you coming up